hi i'm wiching from msr beijing lab i'm
going to briefly introduce our research
work on behalf of all the collaborators
causal learning discovering causal
relations for out of distribution
generalization
as we know machine learning especially
deep learning is suffering from the
robustness issue
and this brings difficulties to apply
deep learning into safety critical tasks
like health care and security
the reason is traditional machine
learning heavily relied on the idea
assumption
when the tested samples are out of
distribution
the sampling buyers or confounder
distribution in the training data can be
broken
then the model will learn the spurious
correlation for example the digital
label is spuriously correlated with the
color and showed us the animal and the
background
so our goal is to learn a robust
predictor that can generalize well on
the out of distribution samples
our main idea is to incorporate causal
environments into the model by library
by level reading the structural causal
equations we split the latent variables
into causal and non-causal ones
if
it only contributes to the generation of
output y we call it causal latent factor
if it contributes to both the generation
of input x and output y we call it
non-causal latent factor
for example the causal factor is the
animal in the picture and the non-causal
factor is the background
the generation of the input and output y
from the two latent variables is
environment across all the domains
but the latent variable may have
confunder including the unobservable
confounder c
and
the
observer
observed domain variable d
the generation of the confounder and the
latent variables is not invariant across
the domains
we call our model latent causal
environment environment model
abbreviated as lassim
we prove that if the correlations
between the causal and non-causal
factors are diverse enough among the
domains
the cost factor is identifiable only
based on the observation data
and the according predictor for the
output is invariant
guided by this theoretical result we
propose to fit the drawing distribution
of input and output by the generative
models in the training
during test we maximize the likelihood
of the input over latent factors to
learn the causal factors for the
prediction
we compare our message with several
baselines on od tasks like nicole
columnist and the public data success
for aldeemer's disease called adni
as shown in the table
our method achieved consistently better
accuracy
we also visualize that our method can
successfully disentangle the causal
factors from the non-causal ones
falsely a four color administ in the
first row we interpolated the causal
factors in lassim the generating images
changes from 0 to 7.
in the second row we interpolated the
non-causal vector d that generated
images
changed from red to green
and on nickel as shown in the last
column in each subfigures the high
response area of our methods are
concentrated on the simatic area where
the erm this line can contain the
contextual features
so if you are interested in this work
please see more details in our paper
any questions or comments will be much
appreciated
feel free to contact me look forward to
the discussions and the potential
collaborations in this promising
research direction